G I just got it money my first time I
got 200k what do I do I'm like well if
you don't know what to do invest in t-
bills and get your five points on your
money instead of letting s a bank with
no risk if you do know what you're doing
I think certain stocks that kick
Dividends are interesting real estate's
great right I lived in my own cocoon for
15 years in the wine business I didn't
know [__] I didn't grow up with all this
information there were there was no
[__] Monday money [__] podcast
like the dorks on CNBC were not catching
my attention right so I didn't know this
stuff and you know it's why I love
putting out information because you like
I said on stage I've my public uh life
is really made for the 15-year-old me
I've come to realize you know and so
like it's really cool that all these
kids coming up or not even the kids it's
cool right now that a 53-year-old who's
going through a transition in her his
life is listening to this podcast for
free while she's working out or driving
to work and people are spitting real
knowledge you guys me like and the other
150,000 people there's a lot of [__]
there's a lot of people like looking to
do short-term stuff but anyway I'm an
entrepreneur who you know believes that
nice guys finish first talked about
flipping and eBay and garage sing walk
us through the concept of that for our
listeners that's a good one because it's
weird I'm I've been a little bit on a
roll on this and when I say on a roll
I've probably had 10 to 15 people in the
street or the airport or at Comic-Con
New York where I was for an hour before
I flew out here ref the garage sale
thing it comes up a lot but just it's
hot right now the last 3 4 days anyway
for everyone was listening in
2017 I just kind of like had this moment
was like you know what like I've talk
all about like oh invest in the next
Twitter next Facebook one thing I do
well and one thing I recommend everybody
who's listening that does content you
need to read your DMs that's where you
get the insights that's where you know
where people's real feelings are and I
was getting a lot of like and I was
starting to get bigger at the time and I
was getting a lot of like yo bro I [__]
with you but like [__] you like who's
got 25 bands to [__] put into a
startup I got $93 in my Wells Fargo and
I got enough of that that I was like
okay Bet like I get it let me and I kind
of like you know I was like what what
did I do you know cuz my Dad paid me
five bucks an hour and I wanted money I
was like [__] I was doing garage sales
so and so I just started talking about
it and then I did the 2017 flip
challenge you can go Google it right now
2017 flip challenge Gary ve and you'll
find the premise which is if you have
debt or if you have less than if you
less than $10,000 in your bank
account which a lot of people do I think
people that are fortunate kind of lose
touch then buying and selling stuff that
you buy at flea markets garage sales
thrift stores storage lockers Facebook
Marketplace
Craigslist is real money like it's real
and what I like about it is people a lot
of people who don't know how to make
money any other way really love it now
that it's been out there for like six
years the amount of people who are like
yo I was I've never known how to make
money my whole life I always worked at
this or that like everybody kind of
knows something so you go to a garage
sale like I know what toys are worth on
and video games just cuz I've studied it
for so long but vintage clothes like
records like here's the reality 90% of
the stuff at a garage sale
that is being sold for a dollar or two
is 10 bucks on eBay sure and then you
get crazy hits so you know I would go to
Instagram right now or Tik Tok and put
hash garage sale Flip or yard sale flip
you'd be stunned get educated we're not
going to get to it here but on the make
money side especially for all the people
listening who've got 87 bucks that 87
bucks can really be 10K and the problem
is with the way the world all the free
information's good but on the flip side
all the kids that are listening right
now that have 87 bucks
they think they need to make a million
right and I'm like listen make 10,000
before you make a million and when you
get the 10,000 figure out have to get
100,000 and then you can get to a millon
you know and getting from 87 at you're
30 and you've never had any money to a
million it's not going to happen you're
going to chase fads you're going to
chase [__] scams and so you know I
I'm really about that flip I mean I did
it the other day I literally because I
still filmed something called trash talk
on you know I've done 10 or 11 episodes
where I just go do it and it's just
there it's there and I'm really excited
about it I think most people should be
able to make $500 in profit and like
look if you're listening right now and
here's the other thing it's fun for
certain people the game is fun
especially if you have a partner like
it's a great father daughter father son
BR me and AJ right are real tight we're
11 years apart I think both of us would
say besides Jets football that garage
sailing and maybe even garage sailing
more cuz during Jets football we're just
being maniacs and focusing but when you
wake up at 6:30 and you go to Burger
King get a coffee and then you drive 25
minutes to the townwide by the way if
you want to find if you want to really
Crush garage sales Google townwide
garage sale because you don't want to
spend all morning going to four a lot of
towns around the country will do a
townwide garage you can hit a 100 in
four hours so that's a little hack
anyway you know but you have to drive 40
minutes to get to the town that's doing
it so you know for me and AJ when he was
13 14 15 16 and I was 24 25 26 those
were real moments when we were driving
from 7:00 to 8:00 a.m. where he's
talking about like liking girls and like
school and like life and like I'm in my
young I'm talking about building dad's
business and like it really bonded us
and so for a lot of people I've gotten
emails of like them and their best
friend became closer because you're
grinding and what's funny is for a lot
of people that don't have money you know
this they also are commonly very cliche
the person that wakes up at 11:00 a.m.
on a Saturday right now they're waking
up at 6: 30 Yep they're getting that
discipline they're getting home by 1112
it's kind of the same they realize they
didn't even you know sometimes they like
I don't want to [__] with my bowling or
my go for my or hanging my boys or the
college football like be home by it and
it gets them going and it changes it and
so yeah I like flip life I like it a lot
because I also once you get the first
hook one guy cuz I'm so into it still if
someone like yo Gary ve you really put
me on like flip life like changed my
life I'm always like yo what was your
first big one I'm like what was your
first big one they're like you'll never
believe it I bought [__] 40 bucks for
a thousand [__] CDs and sold them all
for some were rare and this Pink Floyd
one was like 80 bucks and I was like
what the [__] and that was H and that's
like I'm still about that life that's so
fun so let's say someone starts making
some money right they hit 10 grand then
20 and then 30 and 40 I got a big one on
this I wonder if any of your guests have
said this I really thought a lot about
this because I do a lot of investing
wrong a lot what do I mean by that I'm
not Diversified in real estate enough if
you're going by the the book sure I'm
not in the real I'm not in the stock
market enough if you go buy the book
most of my stock is cuz I invested in
companies that went public and I still
have the stock I do a lot of things
wrong I I invest in very highrisk early
stage companies I love Collectibles
which are very volatile cards nfts art
things like that I'm self-aware of what
I'm trying to accomplish which is I'm
trying to maximize Joy not maximize
money-making so you have to know who you
are so for me I know that yes I have
these lofty goals buying the Jets but I
feel like I'm going to do that through
operating vriends in Vayner X give me
that
chance and and I get joy I wouldn't say
it's gambling but it's definitely in
between gambling and investing the right
way that I like because it makes me
happy and you know like I get you know
Facebook and Twitter like these
Investments I mean it's going to take me
a while to lose enough money to offset
how big those wins were sure
but then you have to know yourself for
example here's a weird one like t- bills
like if you don't know like do you know
that most of the [__] people who are
listening should just get five and a
half six% of their money yeah great like
like that didn't exist three four years
ago shit's changed money's expensive now
so interest rates are up so a lot of
people who are sit like I mean all day
long people like Gary ve I just got into
money my first time I got 200k what do I
do I'm like well if you don't know what
to do invest in t- bills and get your
five points on your money instead of
letting sit in Bank with no risk right
if you do know what you're doing you
know I think certain stocks that kick
Dividends are interesting like a Pepsi
it's not going away tomorrow and they're
kicking you know and that's kicking
dividends and then real estate's great
like like I think if you like it my Dad
loved it that's where almost all his
investing went into almost none of mine
has I'm I'm bored by it like I
understand I bought a building and
people are paying rent but I'm like I
don't know like I don't like it even
though it's great and like by the way
most of the last generation's
billionaires came from Real Estate cuz
all the tax laws written so positive
real estate's great great if you get off
on that and then there's alternative
[__] like you know what I will say for
sure and this is what my number one
belief is is that it's the cross-section
of something you like and something you
understand I hate when people invest in
[__] they don't understand because
someone smart told them please my
friends do not invest in [__] you do not
understand which is why I like people
buy though I don't do it I love people
buying stocks of their favorite
companies yes if you're about
Starbucks and like you do a little
reading and you're like they seem normal
like the see everything's chill like
that's a good investment buy some
Starbucks shares like you know the the
those stock markets a good bet like the
stock market will work as long as
America's around so that's a very good
bet um so that I think it's a game of
enjoying it and a game of understanding
it I think that's what people should
focus on part of my speech I say raise
your hand if you think Apple will be
here in five years what about Netflix
how about Facebook Walmart
okay raise your hands again if you shop
at Walmart do you buy Netflix you buy
Apple do you have Facebook okay if you
believe in them that much you'll spend
$1,500 on the iPhone why don't you buy
1,500 bucks of stock that's right right
buy 500 bucks of Walmart you like
Walmart buy 500 bucks y I don't have to
go put in your life savings go buy a
little bit of these things over the
course of your life well what people
don't understand is how advantageous it
is to invest too because they don't know
rules I didn't know them I didn't know
that if you lost an investment you can
write that off against an investment you
made money on and play the Arbitrage
there so like you know we we don't we
were not educated on money well which is
why I'm glad yeah I get it and so look
chat gbt and Google like and YouTube
like learn like the demo that I feel is
listening to this right now just moves
too fast right when they first hit money
either in buying something it's okay to
reward reward yourself you listen I grew
up with only kids that had nothing I
grew up in very lower middle class
environments so I get when you finally
do something you go to buy crazy car or
you know watch and listen let's call a
spade a spade 90% time dudes do that to
get girls like like like I get the human
psychology of it all I would just say
slow down a second because if you've got
200,000 if you slow down a second just
slow down you're more likely to have 2
million because if you go fast you're
back to zero right and we all know that
every one of us in this motor home know
people that got into some money and and
went to zero straight zero or cuz they
were insecure and [__] up it went up
their nose right or it went to Vegas or
like you know slow it down everybody
like life is long like of course have
fun like when I talk about like you know
this I've for a long time talk about
like don't buy all this stuff and a lot
most of the people in these circles are
mad at me I'm not saying don't buy a
Lambo sure I'm not I'm saying don't buy
four and and and and by the way even
that's fine do you know why you're
buying it yeah like if you like have
loved cars your whole life read car
magazines like like I go into a car
there's no enjoyment there's no like I I
don't like all my friends who like I I
know genuinely like it like I don't
understand like the speed you don't get
I don't like that and so for me that's
not right if that's right for you then
that's amazing but most people buy logos
to flex to close gaps of insecurity and
so that's what worries me because if
you're just into a little money and you
decide to buy a Rolex because actually
insecure and you're not confident you
need that Flex to rub elbows with me or
to hit on that girl then you've got
other work that you need to do and that
that money is not going to be well spent
it's going to be a short-term high and
then you're going to be in like a weird
place and so money's a it's an exposure
of your truth so anyway back to
investing to stay on track [__] you
understand I like it
tar Gary taught you a trick a few weeks
ago and immediately you you got like
600,000 I don't even know the number
600,000 likes or something this makes me
so happy this was like two weeks ago and
it's like I this feels like very
gratifying to me it's like instant
validation to giving good strategy it's
not even a trick no he like tagged me in
sorry he tagged me in the screenshot and
he was like look 2.6 million views 18
million views 12 million views and the
it was the same week that you told them
it's um you have a lot of valid points
and um the way my brain set up you break
stuff down really well and understand it
you know and um
we're algorithm junkies so we try to
figure out where what what hits what
unlocks it what what kicks it
underpriced attention the Arbitrage the
opportunity yes so you kicked off that
uh you know front front space still
photo with the text and then the video
that follows y genius yeah it's funny
for everybody to give a Clarity
Instagram's tougher now supply and
demand it's not like it was when we were
kicking in 2014 you know like there's
more and a lot of the demand went Tik
Tok and YouTube shorts but the supply is
super up yesterday more people posted on
Instagram than ever before czy so it
gets harder so you're looking for what I
call Strategic organic content like what
are the what's the organic content move
meaning of course there's ads but what's
the what's the respectful proper back to
like getting buff right like they're
steroids and there's putting in the work
and eating protein in those ratios and
listen I'm not interested in I know the
snakes just all over the [__] place
um you know like um and yeah I was
pumped at you caught me at a good time
cuz it was a revelation for me only 30
days earlier like we're constantly
testing we have what I think I do well
that I want more people to do well is I
have the humility for it to bomb I don't
fear somebody coming to Gary V's page
and seeing 880,000 views you got 14 like
you suck like I'm like I'm okay you suck
too like what are we talking I don't
know tomor right so we take a lot of
creative risks most people can't get out
of posting the same [__] over and over
cuz they need the same results even
though it's declining MH so we find shed
the one we found on this one was instead
of just posting the video which
everybody's been doing for a while now
first post an image that that kind of
previews what the video is going to be
as a video and so it's a two poost
Carousel Image First video second and
I'm I'm so happy you're seeing results
and the reason I'm saying it out loud
here is and you know this about me Dan
like I'm weird when it comes to someone
who hacks I I go from finding it to
immed telling everyone like all my best
buds are like yo can't you just sit on
this for like a month like don't you and
I'm like nobody's taking for me like I'm
going to get mine regardless and like
and I like that PE I I it feels nice
like it feels nice to be admired when
you're helping going to your last part
charity feels nice like like you know
when you don't have anything and then
you get money you you really like
especially in the beginning you're like
yo I'm not sure I can give this away you
know like I remember being young and
hearing like Bill Gates and all those
guys were giving away 99% I was like yo
that shit's crazy now I understand
especially with kids you know you don't
want to leave you know leaving kids
those characters leaving kids billions
of dollars it's actually going to make
them unhappy so that's actually my next
question yeah you know before we go into
charity the biggest charity is
intellectual
generosity and I know I'm very good at
my craft and I know I'm at the top of
the game and I'm proud I watch people
far less capable than me hold everything
to themselves scarcity mindset wanting
to pass you or you or me or you in
followers and that's their [__] I
don't see it that way I get I looked at
someone's account today who I was like
whoa and I was like pumped did they're
explo like I I don't know like I don't
know how to boo right I know how to boo
in football I hate everybody but you
know what's so funny actually make I'll
make this point before we get to the
last part do you know that being a Jets
fan this is real talk actually makes me
understand people meaning in real life I
have this almost borderline delusional
though I know it's fully grounded in
practicality optimism I have no Envy I
have no jealousy I have no anger I have
no Darkness I really don't it's kind of
scary it's a [__] blessing but in
football I have all that I'm jealous of
patriot fanss I'm sad that we didn't get
Patrick Mahomes when we could have
drafted him and it's all this resem it's
40 Years of pain right and and it lashes
out like I'm not I'm I'm like really
scared somebody's going to fil me at a
Jets game one day it's going to ruin the
whole the whole [__] the whole nice
image is finished I'm not nice and the
people are listening I'm really not I
like there's like some inside jokes with
my friends like I once yelled at this
80-year-old man it was really
inappropriate like I yell at kids like
I'm I'm on tilt I feel that pain I feel
that anger like I wanted like Taylor
Swift was sitting right above me at the
Jets Chiefs game like I was mad at that
box I like adore Ryan Reynolds but he
was there I was like [__] you Ryan like
but like for real though and he's the
[__] best but for those 3 hours I
wanted to rip his face off and it's a
pretty face like so like I'm like man
that's how people feel in real life I
treat Jets football but that's a silly
thing that's football that's
Entertainment that's escapism people
treat [__] like that in real life the
world is trying to make us more tribal
which makes us hate us each other more
I'm I'm kind of very team human like
color skin race gender religion like I'm
I struggle with that [__] I don't want
to hate anybody why especially when I
don't know you like and if I know you
and you're a bad person I don't hate you
I feel bad for you I have compassion I
have empathy so anyway I think about
that [__] so so two parts on the charity
side of yes one you
mentioned Gary ve is Gonna Keep building
companies we got like 2,500 employees
forer media and all that stuff and all
these Investments like you end up
becoming a multi multi multi-billionaire
and who knows maybe even crazier more
what happens for the kids I don't know
the truth is I don't know meaning I
definitely as I've done started doing
Estate Planning in the last decade am
not where I thought I was going to be 10
years ago meaning I do feel
uncomfortable leaving tons of money for
to children I think it's a little scary
of course I really do but then you're
especially from an immigrant like where
I'm from like it's real family BL out so
then you get into like you know is that
it's it's a very complex thing here's
what I would say a couple things real
talk everyone you earned it you decide
don't let me someone this whole like
judging each other's [__] like first
just tune out everyone you earned it you
want to burn it you burn it you want to
give it to dolphins give it to dolphins
not the Miami Dolphins animals right you
want to give all of it just to your kid
and not a dollar to charity masle T this
is you know to me I really think that
people are I think we're really bad at
judging and and I think we need to be
accountable so T directly I'm not sure I
definitely have come to realize
especially if I'm keep on this
trajectory look my point of view is this
do you know what it's like to get a
million dollars right that's insane yeah
like if I had that like like at 18 I
would have been like it would have been
over I might have the Jets and the Nicks
by that so if if your kids are capable
they're not going to need a whole lot
plus it's for a lot of kids it [__]
them up I've met a lot of rich kids now
cuz of my life the last 15 years man I'm
not sure who's worse like I I actually
genuinely believe if you could be born
with little but have a happy house or
born with a lot and have an unhappy
house that's not even a fight but I
think it's even scarier I think if
you're if you've got a lot and you're in
a happy house and you got a little and
you're in a happy house the little and
Happy House person won because they've
been taught from the get that money
doesn't buy happiness whereas the rich
kid might not know they might just think
well we're happy because we got a driver
and a private plane and so the answer is
I don't know the answer is I'm sure it
will EB and flow the other thing I don't
know is when am I going what's happening
in my life uh let me talk about things
that people don't talk enough about let
me give you a scenario while people are
listening and judging what if one of my
grandchildren is Special Needs yeah you
know like I don't think we do enough of
this yeah like I do you know real talk
why I don't judge anyone like really
like actually I just don't know what the
[__] going on in her life I'm watching
everybody walk around the internet and
Society just throwing nothing but
judgment I wish we th like you know
people like [__] this guy he throws
shade shade's easy judgment's crazy
telling people what they should be doing
you know nothing you know nothing you
should post about this do you know that
if person posted about that they have
death
threats you should you should do this
with your money okay well you should do
this with like I don't understand so you
know I think for me I I I don't feel I
mean I have a will and it it's split up
at this point to kids and charity but I
may change it and like cuz things will
change and we'll
see but I do let me say one thing
charity most of my life so I would say
97 cents on the dollar of everything
I've done in my life has been incredibly
private
because I think that's how I was taught
like you know it's funny like probably
one of the reasons I don't flex a lot is
is the same reason I don't really make a
lot of my charity work public I think
there's something in the way that my
parents saw the world that became my
framework right it's like you keep quiet
in some ways I think I but I don't judge
I you know let me phrase I think there
was a time a decade ago that I was a
little cynical to people that were
overly loud about donating you know my
my Jersey Street [__] radar would go
off but I've come to realize like I
don't want to be a judger either and you
now if you know you know like okay
they're using that as a disguise for the
bad [__] that happens but there are just
other people that like get real pride in
that and more importantly they're
motivating others to do it and so that's
my yeah I mean I think very public but I
don't say amounts I say I show them how
they can do TR yeah and honestly even
like amounts like you know I think it
goes I've started to change my point of
view on that this is what's fun about
let me say something real quick to the
kids which by the way is everyone if a
99 year old Grandma's watching you're a
kid
um you get to change your
mind right you like that one right I
love it right cuz you've changed your
mind on [__] I've Chang my like you get
to change your mind and soar I'm glad
I'm so happy kids have like by the way
maybe if I was 14 and listening to this
podcast maybe I wouldn't have had that
point of view as a 20 and 30y old about
charity right and maybe I did leave an
opportunity to bring awareness to
charity water and pencils of promise and
the cronn and& kidus foundation and
reform maybe I've left too much
attention on the table by maybe having
too much pride and the humility in the
class that comes along with not flexing
it you know like so it's I mean this to
everybody like give yourself the grace
to change your mind I want people the
reason I post about toy drives and
tipping dinners and homeless backpacks
is so people can replicate it and
thousands and thousands thousands people
replicate it and so when you talk about
I even heard about pencil the promise
because you yeah you weren't posting
about it but I just heard about it and
then all of a sudden I became obsessed
with it because of that and that was a
fun one for me cuz I was bad student and
I'm a famously bad student but but I
think about friction in Ghana it's not
like America with the education system
where we all go and it doesn't work for
half of us cuz we are creative or
entrepreneurial when you look at the
math that if you build a school in one
of those places like what the trajectory
of that people here talk about
generational wealth they you put a
school it's generational wealth they go
from living a life of a dollar a day to
like [__] in Haiti it's a dollar a day
right people living on yeah bro we're
lost out here wored about all sorts of
dumb [__] we grew up thinking it's rude
to talk about money obviously here at
the podcast we think it's rude to not
talk about money because we need your
friends family and followers to know
about taxes salary loans rent how to
make money invest money save money 401ks
and everything between we just need to
have these discussions so talk to your
friends family followers about money ask
questions research it by the way real
quick on that chat GPT everyone you you
know Google's Google changed the world
chat GPT you can ask that bot very very
specific questions hey I'm a plumber y I
make 39,000 a year I get to save $1,000
a year what should I do enter you would
be blown away what AI can do you can be
very spec can't do that on Google hey I
have $18,000 in debt from this credit
card company I'm paying 7.3 like like
get start using AI for your advantage
not something you heard about or
demonize or don't understand don't don't
understand is unacceptable right I don't
get it okay Google it YouTube it if
you're like me and can't read for [__]
and listen like so you know for a lot of
people wanting to learn about money
could you imagine having real inform
like could you imagine sitting down with
somebody that knew most things that's
awesome isn't that a cool way to think
about like imagine sitting down with
[__] Yoda getting all the answers is
no try just literally type in [__] be
super specific you'll learn how to start
using AI which may change your
trajectory and you can start answering
[__] for
[Music]
yourself